nevada's mass mandate lift is a big step
forward some feel for big businesses
christian gossip is joining us now live
in studio with how some are reacting to
today's announcement well brian and
denise let me tell you businesses along
the strip are quickly following sue
dropping their masks after the
requirements the requirement was
implemented about two years ago now they
tell us they're hoping this is the
beginning of the end of the pandemic
venues like drey's at the cromwell says
this is a breath of fresh air they added
that even though their venue is half
indoors and half outdoors health and
safety is priority for both guests and
employees and it will continue to be
enforced now they don't expect bigger
crowds for now until the spring break
and the summer season comes around now
the strat's vp stephen thayer tells us
this will help las vegas get to that
full recovery stage
it sends a message that we're ready to
get back to the group business and ready
to get back to some normalcy
also the second piece is the
international piece you know it was all
it was very confusing i think for
a lot of the countries coming in of what
the rules were and it's different in
this state and different in that state
and i think it again it starts to feel a
little bit normal
well thayer hopes the mandate change
will entice people to attend conventions
in person and have a positive impact on
international travel as well now he also
tells me he's hoping that entertainment
will see a boost in attendance now that
face masks are not required he stressed
that any employee or guest that chooses
to keep the mask on will be respected
now coming up at six o'clock what
properties in the downtown area are
telling us about this mass lift
christian castle is live local now